اصيب عدد من الفلسطينيين في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف منزل عائله ابو شراره في منطقه
الزوايده وسط قطاع غزه وادى القصف الى
اندلاع حريق هائل في
المكان استف منزل يعود الى عائله ابو شرار
في هذه اللحظات في
منطقه الزوايا هذا المنزل المشتعل كليا في
منطقه الزوايده منزل يعود لعائله ابو شرار
تم تدمير المنزل بشكل كامل كما نشاهد
واياكم اشتعال النيران بشكل
مكثر تعمل الق القاض على افا هذا
الحريق مقم الدفاع المدني الان تحاول
السيطره على هذا الحريق الكبير الذي نجم
عن الاستهداف من قبل المقاتلات الحربيه
لمنزل عائله ابو
شرابط
يا شباب
ه
ه المنزل مخنب الكامل لكن اصاباتهم من
الماره ومن الجيران لهذا
المنزل شغل يا خليل فسل يا ابراهيم
حرر لي البربيش حرر لي اياه حرر لي اياه
خليل خليه يرجع اني
ه حتى اللحظه انتشال اكثر من 15 مصابا من
المنازل المجاوره لهذا المنزل
المستهدف المنزل المخلاب الكامل ولكن قوه
القصف وقوه الصواريخ التي سقطت على هذا
المنزل ادت الى تناتر الزجا والحجاره
والركام على المنازل
المجاوره